et
[Musique]
la première expédition shadow qui est
arrivée sur la terre pour exterminer
jugeait les shadoks notre avance
prudemment dans leur capsule terrestre
le cosmo autobus
[Musique]
gégène angie be pour passer bien n'était
pas dupe il ya longtemps que les arbres
radar djiby avait détecté tout ça et
pour s'amuser tout en prenant le thé
avec gêne il regardait sur leur écran le
cosmo autobus avancer il faut dire qu'en
plus il avait planté de ci de là dans
les forêts quelques passages à niveau le
feu rouge et passages cloutés et les
shadoks notre cru dans à chaque fois
s'arrête l'egypte il leur avait préparé
un petit itinéraire de sorte que le
cosmos opus shadow fit plusieurs fois le
tour de la terre ait eu quelques petits
accidents amusant en particulier à
l'heure du thé un jour quand même voilà
le cos moto bus shadoks qui arrive chez
gégène les exterminateurs attrape gènes
sont mis en batterie gégène est
cordialement invitée à venir six
attrapés gégène malheureusement n'était
pas là il était parti déjeuner dans un
sens cela
mieux pour les chaînes au foot parce que
entendre normal vous pensez bien non
n'aurait fait qu'une bouchée mais ce
jour là il ne voulait pas trop se
charger l'estomac et les shadows claude
finir au garde-manger
évidemment ce n'était pas une fin très
glorieuse pour des cosmonautes mais eux
personnellement il préfèrerait ça la
guerre est elle finie non assurez-vous
d'autres shadoks suivait
[Musique]